Speaker 1: . I have a voicemail here from
someone who is not pleased with my position
on outdoor masks.
Now, I think it's really important for me
to state again, my position is that I think
I am going to listen to the CDC unmasks.
My position has been that all along.
And this person, like many in the audience,
are sort of upset with me about me saying
I think the CDC is right about pulling back
on outdoor masking in most situations.
Let's take a listen to this and go piece by
piece.
Speaker 7: Hey, David, you say you not for
wearing masks because again,
Speaker 1: I've been wearing a mask outdoors
this entire time, I didn't think it was necessary,
but I've been doing it because I just follow
the CDC guidelines.
The CDC guidelines have now changed.
It's not that I am for or against.
I am listening to the CDC.
Speaker 7: My question for you is, would you
be OK with someone smoking at the same table
as you outdoors or smoking right next to the
door of your office building?
Speaker 1: So I guess two things.
They're smoking at the same table.
I don't really know any smoker.
So there's no reason somebody should be smoking
at my table.
If you mean the next table over, there's a
bunch of differences here.
Covid particles are water droplets or aerosolized
liquid.
If you want to go in that direction, cigaret.
Smoke is smoke.
So the physics of it is totally different.
Covid particles aren't carcinogenic.
They don't have a cumulative effect over your
lifetime.
Secondhand smoke is something that it has
a cumulative effect on the body over lifetime.
There is some amount of covid particles that
could make you sick.
And if it's below that threshold, then that's
it.
Accumulating cigaret smoke over a lifetime
is bad.
So the analogy is the same one Tucker Carlson
made, but it's not a good one.
Speaker 7: Or smoking right next to the open
window of your apartment.
I'm guessing you would complain about that.
And I'm asking what evidence you have that
carcinogens in cigarets are able to move as
far.
Or they are able to move further than covid
virus.
Speaker 1: Yeah, listen, I these are two completely
different things.
Smoke is smoke.
Covid particles are are liquid.
So it's just none of it is making sense to
me.
We also know that it's not like the covid
and cigarets are also dissimilar in that essentially
no one's getting sick outside.
Before anybody was vaccinated, the estimate
is one out of a thousand cases were transmitted
outdoors.
And we have to believe that those few outdoor
cases were people doing obviously stupid things,
a big crowd on a hiking trail or at a concert
or whatever the case may be.
There's just no analogy.
We know it's not an issue.
People have not been getting sick in that
way.
Speaker 7: Particles.
And I'm also wondering if you're not for wearing
masks outdoors.
If someone goes from outdoors to indoors,
they put their mask in their pocket.
What's preventing the particles on one side
of the mask from infecting the other side
of the mask?
Well, it's in the pocket and the particles
collected on the mask from getting onto the
hands of people.
Oh, God, how are you?
How do you expect people to manage this?
I don't think most people can.
Speaker 1: It's what's been the I mean, the
entire time, you know, you go in somewhere,
you put your mask on, then at some point the
mask goes in your pocket.
This is basically surface transmission.
Surface transmission has been shown to be
almost zero.
Remember, at the beginning, all this stuff
about bleach, your vegetables and all of this
different stuff, it's been determined it's
not necessary.
Mask in the pocket.
Then on the face, the particles move around.
That's not how people are getting sick.
So I'm not worried about that.
There's no evidence that I need to worry about
that better.
Speaker 7: That it was just in and out of
your pocket, you've just moved everything
the mask has collected into your pocket.
Speaker 1: Anyway, yeah, right.
But again, we now know that that type of surface-to-surface
stuff is not how people are getting sick.
So my question to these folks is, if you agreed
with the CDC all along, why do you suddenly
now not believe what the CDC is saying?
I've just been listening to the CDC from the
start.
I think that that voicemail is completely
antithetical to any known science.
We will have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about how Americans are seeing
Biden compared to Barack Obama.
We will talk about the return of New York
Police Department's robot dog.
And we will talk about a controversial hand
gesture on Jeopardy, which may not be what
it seems.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Get access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at Join Catman dot com ICRA.